Microsoft gets a fresh start on
the web with Project Spartan,
and what exactly
are these beacons
trying to tell your smartphone?
I'm Rob Dodson.
This is "LazyWeb."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fire up your iPhones
because Facebook
has just announced that React
Native is now open source.
Demonstrated at this
year's React Conf,
React Native is
a compiled target
which lets you run your
React app in native iOS.
The project ships with
a bundle of components,
and there's already
a catalog of add-ons
available at react.parts.
Building a web
for everyone means
making your site
accessible, but finding
good examples of accessible
websites can be tough.
A11ywins is a new Tumblr
created by Marcy Sutton
with daily updates highlighting
accessible websites.
Featured sites like
status.modern.ie
demonstrate how complex sites
can be made usable for all.
The wait is finally over
because Polymer 0.8 has landed.
The new version brings with
it dramatic performance
improvements and
benchmarks showing
a 5x speedup in mobile
Safari and an 8x boost
in desktop Firefox.
You can get a first
look at this new release
in this week's episode of
"Polycast" by yours truly.
Fetching resources is
a major bottleneck,
but what if you could tell
the browser to preload them?
Preload link elements
tell the browser
that it should download
a resource ahead of time
since this resource
will be needed later
during page navigation.
A recent intent to
implement signals
that preload links may
be coming to Chrome
in the very near future.
Move over IE because it's time
for developers to meet Spartan.
Branded as a new browser for
the next iteration of Windows,
Spartan is a stripped-down fork
of IE 11 aimed at being lean,
mean, and standards-compliant.
You can catch "The Verge's"
deep dive into Spartan
or take it for a spin yourself
by downloading the Windows
Technical Preview.
The physical web
is all around us,
or it will be soon thanks
to this set of beacons
created by Blesh.
Started as an experiment
by a team at Google,
the physical web project
aims to give users
interaction on demand by
linking physical objects to web
applications.
Beacons transmit signals
which are picked up your phone
and allow you to
open applications
specific to your surroundings.
Now it's time for a solar
system in your browser.
To all you LazyWebbers out
there, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]